spider-man homecoming was directed by
John Watts who made the film cop car a
pretty overlooked film with Kevin Bacon
check it out to get a chance and stars
Tom Holland as spider-man reprising his
role that he was introduced in in civil
war and this is the sixth big screen
spider-man adaptation we've seen since
2002 and we are finally getting to see
the vulture portrayed by Michael Keaton
in this film who really likes to play
characters that are like flying creature
related here we're introduced to a Peter
Parker who's in high school for the
entire movie he has high school kid
problems he has to get to school on time
he's got to make it to homecoming dance
he's at a decathlon he has to do all
this stuff while bouncing being
spider-man that's what makes spider-man
great the character the fact that he's
just a normal kid who has everyday
problems and Stanley has said countless
times that that's why he feels the
public relates to spider-man so much
because most people are afraid of
spiders so why does everyone like
spider-man because he's like us
he's got everyday problems but he's also
a superhero and Tom Holland portrayed
both spider-man and Peter Parker
beautifully the character has a lot of
innocence and a lot of purity and that's
what's so important about Peter Parker
it's not just the fact that he has
superhero powers but he's an everyday
kid in school with problems but he's
also this amazing superhero at the same
time he's very naive and he's very
innocent and they captured that really
well and I could not be happier with
this iteration of the character because
I'm a humongous fan he's been one of my
favorites my whole life and so whenever
I see a spider-man movie I guess I
probably judge it more harshly than most
would because the character is so close
to my heart which is why I haven't liked
a spider-man movie in 13 years
haha that's bad this is easily the best
that Spidey has been since oh four this
is an adaptation that understands the
character but also understands that it
needs to be something different this
isn't just another rehash of what we've
already seen before one of the things
that I really could
stand about the first amazing spider-man
was that it basically went through the
exact same motions that Sam Raimi did in
Oh to accept nowhere near as fun and
nowhere near as well directed or written
it was the same old shit just in a
different way
homecoming is very much so its own film
no other spider-man film is like this
the filmmaker said while they were
making it that they wanted to make a
high school movie they were inspired by
teenage high school films and it's very
clear while watching it some might not
like that because there's a surprising
amount of downtime in this movie that
you would normally not expect in a
superhero film or a spider-man film let
alone because you wanted to be swinging
around being spider-man a lot but this
movie does take a lot of time to show
Peter in school yes he has his crushes
yes he's a gigantic nerd and people
don't like him and Flash Thompson picks
on him but at the same time you're
building appreciation for him as a youth
not just for him in his suit being
spider-man the movie allows you to have
those moments where you can just watch
him trying to be a kid because as I said
that's what's so important about the
comics and that character is that you
feel that balance it was also really
exciting to finally see vulture in a
spider-man film because back in the day
Raimi was going to do that for
spider-man 4 but the plans fell through
and Michael Keaton did a really great
job and not just because I like Michael
Keaton his character had a surprising
amount of depth to him that I was not
anticipating I won't ruin it for you
just in case you guys don't know the
direction his character goes but it took
me off-guard considerably but even
before that they gave you a reason to
care about his plight they also treated
him like a scavenger because he's
basically going around trying to steal
things to use for himself and that's
kind of how a vulture actually does
things like they're scavengers really
all the casting was good Marissa Tomei
as a younger Aunt May was a really nice
change of pace you're going to get
annoyed with certain casting choices if
you're the kind of person that wants
everything to look and feel exactly like
it did in the comics if you're okay with
change you're going to be okay with
certain things that occur in this movie
but if you're the type of person that
wants everything to be exactly the same
way that it was in the comics and will
eventually go online and rant about how
some change was made to one of your
favorite characters and more than likely
some things
going to piss you off in this film which
I can understand but it didn't bother me
and I'm a huge fan of the Spidey comics
what did bother me is the fact that this
movie could also be called spider-man
buy an Audi right now it didn't help
that before the screening started there
was like eight OD commercials and a guy
like talking about how he was extremely
excited about spider-man partnering with
Audi and then during the film you get to
see Spidey driving one and the brake
system is working and stuff like some
guy after the movie ended stood up and
was like I don't understand why
spider-man would need those brake
detecting systems he has spidey sense
I'm like yeah but he's also a kid and
he's never really driven before except
in the film he says in a parking lot so
I like the fact that he needed help in
the car that he's just a kid
he's never driven before he doesn't have
his license that's what makes spider-man
so endearing it's the fact that he is so
innocent still there's an absurd amount
of Audi product placement in this movie
and it got a little annoying after a
while this is the Sony and Marvel
collaboration so of course Sony product
placement is also like I said there is a
lot of downtime in this movie time where
you're just with Peter in high school
and sometimes the pacing can drag it's
nice to experience a more slow-moving
Spider Man film but I can see some young
kids thinking a little boring in fact
one of our friends his six-year-old said
it was kind of boring but he's six so I
mean he just wants to see spider-man
being spider-man this might be the
spider-man movie for comics fans who
just want to see their beloved webhead
portrayed correctly on the screen in the
way they'd like them to they're going to
get that but as I said there are some
changes made to certain characters that
are integral to spider-man and some
people who want everything to be perfect
are going to be upset about that one of
my major flaws with the movie is that I
really wish the action had a more
visceral sense to it that was something
that Raimi did so well his action scenes
were brutal and intense you could feel
the sweat the action scenes in this
movie are enjoyable they're fun
spider-man does spider-man stuff and you
can have a fun time watching it but it
didn't really feel like there were
enough stakes in the action scenes
there's a very elongated boat scene
where the boat splits in half and I felt
that sequence was handled rather
ham-fisted there could have been a lot
more intensity to it and certain things
happen we were like wait did he just
like okay that makes no sense whatever
it's a Spider Man movie he was bit by a
radioactive spider shut the fuck up also
I found that the movie couldn't quite
scape this feeling of being slightly
inconsequential it feels like you're
watching a lot of events that set up
Spider Man to be involved in the Marvel
Universe but it doesn't really feel like
anything of major stakes is happening
where you can get really invested in it
nothing like the ending of the first
spider-man where he's in that abandoned
Hospital getting the shit kicked out of
him and Goblin is talking about how he's
going to kill Mary Jane nothing like in
spider-man 2 when he's got his mask off
and the citizens of that train see him
and he think my god he's going to rip
himself apart there's never a moment
like that in this movie it's a fairly
light-hearted enjoyable watch for some
that might be really great I was hoping
for a little more intensity I was hoping
for something to happen that made me
feel like people were actually in danger
because the body count is also
surprisingly low which again I
understand he's a kid in high school and
this isn't spider-man so much as it is
he's almost spider-man this movie is
kind of like not an origin story about
his powers and Uncle Ben but an origin
story of how he becomes spider-man like
growing from spider boy to Spider Man
it's important and that's one of the
major themes of the movie is whether or
not the suit is what he needs to be
powerful or if you can be Spider Man
without the suit so sometimes yes the
film does feel a little bit
light-hearted and not as exciting or as
intense as I was hoping it was going to
be
Michael chiquinho score is one of the
better recent Marvel scores but it is
still in the shadow of Danny Elfman's
incredible themes that he made for
spider-man and I feel like that's just
always going to be the best spider-man
theme Robert Downey jr. is appearances
in the film where of course entertaining
I mean it's pretty hard to watch Downey
as Tony Stark and not
he'll some level of entertainment but at
the same time there are a lot of moments
in this movie we're like oh there's a
character from that oh there's a
character from that okay this is he's an
Avenger now right he's in the Avenger
universe like there are times where you
feel like you're just watching this and
you're like alright I get it it's
setting up more that's fine
it's just some Marvel films standalone
so well like Winter Soldier is one of
the best where you're like that is a
great Marvel movie it doesn't feel like
it's becoming anything else like I love
Civil War but let's admit it that was a
big like everyone comes together it's a
big Marvel extravaganza setting up all
kinds of things of that like you know
what I mean like some Marvel movies
really standalone really well as
exciting this feels like a perfectly
enjoyable spider-man movie where they
really capture the character and they
played it fairly safe it also addresses
certain things in spider-man movies that
they've never addressed before like what
would happen if there were no buildings
and he had to get somewhere he I guess
he just had to run or what if he was
swinging through a neighborhood that's
kind of low to the ground I guess that's
that sucks the movie does feel like
another Marvel movie in the middle of a
bunch of other Marvel movies but it's
well directed it's well acted and it's a
great interpretation of the character
and I had a lot of fun watching it it's
also pretty funny I'm going to give
spider-man homecoming a be definitely go
out and see this one if you're a major
fan of spider-man I feel like most
people are going to be really happy with
this movie
I enjoyed it overall I'd like to hear
what you guys thought of it when you get
a chance to see it as always guys thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck the NIH's
[Music]